people
[Music]
all right
excuse me myself
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
everything is
last time
[Music]
away
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what up there friends I hope you enjoyed
that little peek of me spinning fire at
the pre-northwest flow Fest jam up in
Seattle at Gas Works Park it was really
cool seeing the system that they all had
set up there and to see them doing
really awesome and safe fire on a
community level so uh kudos to y'all up
there in the Seattle Fire community
um you're going to see more stuff from
Northwest flow Fest here in the next few
weeks I hope uh in the meantime I just
wanted to put out some thank yous
including thank yous to the hosts of uh
Northwest flow Fest for having me up
there but also
um big thanks to the Friends of the
channel that is big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flowfests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
myself by checking out the links that
I've got down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel That
is Becca beckonen thank you so very much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission and finally this video would not
be possible without the kind support of
all of these awesome people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people listed down
in the description helps make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently patreon
supporters but you'd like to become
supporters you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you
will be supporting me in my mission to
bring POI spinning and flow Arts to the
whole wide world so go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to check some of the other fire
performances out that I have done over
the years I'm going to include a link to
a playlist of those down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon
peace